this is the worst thing to ever have in
my feet and lafitte i'm hoping the
federal government will acknowledge some
of that responsibility and
see what they've done to us and try to
help us if i take you on the boat on
intercoastal right here two and a half
miles up you're gonna see the largest
pump in the world uh in the world and
every four seconds it pops up olympics
not swimming forward important pumps
directly onto us it doesn't only
compromise i mean it has potential in my
town
[Music]
we have areas in jefferson parish what
we call outside the levee protection
system these are our southernmost areas
grand isle is right on the gulf um and
then here's lafitte that really are our
most vulnerable areas of the parish
because they just
don't have the levee protection system
they're not protected
by the pumping capacity they're not they
don't have that perimeter defense and
also they're very vulnerable to storm
surge as well surely when you look at
southeast louisiana towns like you know
grand isle
in
parishes like lefouche and terrebonne
they're concerned that they're going to
be left behind too i'm going to be
fighting to make sure they're not left
behind but it but it's a valid concern
that gets raised in times like this it's
not that they are expendable it's um you
know when you're looking at from a
federal perspective and you're looking
at the country as a whole and there's a
limited amount of dollars what you need
to do is find that
manner in which
you're getting the best bang for the
taxpayers dollars nationwide that's not
to say that there can't be state local
or even other federal programs that can
help in that area but it is a
consideration that you have to consider
the nation as a whole we lost inside the
levy protection by inches by inches
according to the gauges that that pump
has increased our levels that lost we
lost our schools our government
buildings you see behind us in hundreds
of homes so i want them to take some
responsibility and invest in here
because we're not going anywhere with
the west closure after every storm
especially major farmer of this
magnitude we want to learn the lessons
we want to do things better and so we
will evaluate uh once we have all the
data we can put it in modeling to
understand really what happened not only
in the feet but throughout the areas
outside of the system so we'll be
working on that and we'll have that data
as soon as we can
[Music]
you give this cajun boy 50 million
dollars i can show you what we can do to
save our people we need more rocks on
the coast we like the soldier in the
rock with the front line if the rocks
would have been on that area three
quarters an hour would have been
protected
with regards to grand isle you know we
are committed to
using the funds we do have to put those
breakwaters in right now what we want to
do is we want to look at a full suite of
opportunities i wouldn't say you know
we're looking at something like a
feasibility study in which we're trying
to determine um
whether there's a project there we're
looking at it from what's the best
project to put in place and we are
considering um you know
a sand dune
uh maybe a clay dune
or a rock and so these are all going to
be considered i just don't have time to
study tomorrow
you know just come in and bring barges
of rocks and where they got to be they
put five of them at the time they worked
in that corner just continued i need 32
segments
[Music]
it seems like any member of congress
should talk to republican or democrat
they've got some kind of frustration
with that relationship on the ground
with the corps of engineers because of
how projects work and come out of
washington with a lot of red tape and
yet it seems to work differently on the
ground in a place like grand isle if
you're putting protection in place there
it's not just to protect grand isle
grand isle is a barrier island and so
everything behind it is protected if you
protect grand out 16 years ago george
bush came in and built levees following
katrina now i'm actually in president
biden and uh uh united states delegation
to to come 16 years later and come come
finish the job come right those wrongs
come protect us i'm not giving up
as long as there's one grain of sand on
this island we're gonna plant the
american flag and we'll stay strong